Hi, I'm Ken Jong and I'm here to answer the internet.
[Inaudible].
Would you rather be filthy rich in 1900 or poor
now? Um, filthy rich in 1900.
So thank you.
Geez. Old, no modern technology.
I know that you're okay with it. I'm not here to explain.
I'm just here to just give a one word answer or you can't pay me. And I mean,
this is,
would you rather have everyone to naked all the time?
Are everyone closed all the time?
So there's no in between you got it, bro. You got it, bro.
Jesus. Yeah. Spoken like a true scientist. You know what I mean?
There is a world where if everyone's naked all the time,
there would be no stigma of being naked. And then, you know, you can shower,
you can, you know, use the bathroom and do it. Yeah.
So everyone naked all the time. It's, you know, it's just a,
there'll be a world where there would just be no labels, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
Cutting that out. Um,
which fictional character would you love to be the out of it?
I mean, you're not real, right? I mean,
you're not everyone here at the office calls you nothing but a phony.
So I think it would be.
[Inaudible].
Hey, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Can we go back? Hey, I'm sorry. No,
that wasn't called for. I said I was sorry. I'm sorry. I'll change.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Your mom and girlfriend switched bodies. Huh?
Only way to get them back to normal is to bang one of them.
Who do you have sex with?
I said I was sorry. I just said it was, I mean,
I feel, if I say girlfriend I'll somehow offend my mom. I don't know why.
[Inaudible] Hey, sick question. You got a sick response. Oh my God.
My mom would be.
Because my mom would somehow bump on that. Now
would you rather always have the hiccups or a headache? That's a great,
I think the hiccups headaches could man, you got a headache constantly.
It's it's yeah, I think it's just too much.
So hiccups saying that headaches.
Headaches, headaches are people don't get it.
There's something that people say when they're just like,
they don't feel that great. Oh, I have a headache. He's like, shut up.
You're sending.
Yeah. Medically. You couldn't be more wrong. I,
I think headaches are. Yeah, I think uh, yeah, I mean, okay.
What is the fiercest animal? What you think you could take in a fight?
A Honeybadger.
Everybody knows that my family knows that Honeybadger like the fiercest animal.
I mean, you seem like, like, I think I could, I just said that.
What did I stutter? I just said that. I think I could take a Honeybadger. Yeah,
it didn't know. Hey, have honey badgers ever gone to Duke? I mean,
I don't think I'm like a smart man. Did they ever go to med school? None.
I figured out a way. I'm smart and I'm from Hollywood. So I know these things,
that mom, girlfriend, and how dare you? How
dare you mom?
I mean, that's the best.